[Music]
in inappropriate pool-party news Sony
pooped in the pool submitted by Mufasa
as Casa oh he has a house as a cave
thousands have signed an online petition
calling for an all-ages nude pool party
to be halted all ages what country we
talk to that's like a Korean spa
let me look at nudist colony no it's
just a Korean spa yeah that's you we
don't hear about like kids like yeah my
dad took me to notice colony here felt
like old weirdos go to news what about
people who grow up and nudists families
how's that legal well they're not
[ __ ] all day that's true that's like
the Korean spa we're not like trying to
[ __ ] each other all day there that's
like if it's like a nudist colony that's
um deep like it well and
long-established nudists calling it
stood this still makes me feel
uncomfortable
all right I actually like that we're
weird that we feel weird about it no
yeah that's everything that's everything
like I wish it was just all cool but
it's not all cool so then I have to be
you're completely right I'll be like if
it's like a rant like if it's a nudist
colony established one that's doing it
and that's kind of normal it's just like
that's an everyday Wednesday for them
you know name me one established nudist
colony maybe in the new baby's an
established nudist colonies worth it's
just that crew yeah and then they have
this feel like the condo please yeah
yeah like our house yeah yeah so but
you're the only one naked in our naked
me and take out our naked and we run
around no guys it's not him and taike
I'm in the room Tycho's fully clothed
and in my arms it's so frigging adorable
though just father and said is growing
around pooping on things yeah but we
know our that's true but if it's like
what if it's like a random like the
[ __ ] the local church pastors like
we're in heaven like that's [ __ ]
weird you know
unless it's been working on was why is
it a lot nude water park too cuz I don't
want my dick dick is it an input water
park
party's all we know yeah my but my booth
haha nude raging waters James big man I
just thought like big slides and then
like everyone's coming down and there's
like skid marks all over have you done
this straight down 100 jobs and
something like that with no like
swimwear your butthole they're just full
cleanse I bet [ __ ] oh no Jose just a big
dream where you give them a pool party
he gives you a [ __ ] Raging Waters
party you know this is really I thought
it was a water park just the pool party
they say that's naked water slides and
wave pool Oh see I'm not it's where I
tap out [ __ ] you floating pubic hair
what's the reason yeah I'm done
imagining I want to hear the story so
it's being organized by a local natures
group called Calgary nude recreation
well there you go there's your
established one yeah so they're a group
known for being nude yeah and so it's
already sold out but there's this
petition on change.org that has more
than eighteen thousand signatures now
and they're trying to get this event
shut down because of the fact that it's
all ages they're saying that they're
putting children at risk of like
predators are like but the book
apparently it's like people take photos
without consent
are they with their parents but it's not
open to public it's just within them
within their group but someone's gotta
work so initially they had this like
grace period where people that want to
try out this like nudist thing that they
can go in with their clothes on and then
like check it out see if their vibe
that's weird that's weird the main thing
that was weird that made it seem like oh
you know if the kids are in there naked
like they can be susceptible to like
some is this an America this is in
Canada Oh Canada Canada's freezing I
gotta raging waters yeah so we asked if
it was open to the public you said yes
oh right and then so they had that thing
right that grace period but then now
like they've updated that and they're
like there's no good not gonna be a
grace period if you want to join you
have to be nude yeah cuz the grace
period makes it weird we're like that's
where the weirdos come in yeah so this
is the Facebook event it was created and
so they're just saying like naked that
looks like a big river I know it there's
like no relation to that that's
so again I'll burn up such a creative
name it is hundred slides in wave pool
Calgary Alberta Alberta the suspense is
killing me what are they gonna do at
this place I don't know you know why
it's weird because I think it's like you
know how in Japan they were gonna have
the the hot water theme park and
everyone's naked there right yeah yeah
it's the own sin like theme park they
would have been naked in that theme park
oh yeah cuz it's a hot water theme park
instance have to be they have to be so
everyone's gonna be in robes and then
they're probably gonna jump in like
butt-naked but there's a there's like a
culture behind that yeah yeah there's
none in Canada that's why it's
associated with perversion and sacrifice
I think too what makes it weird is that
they're promoting it and pushing it for
other people to do it what's their goal
is it to get new members yes so if the
goal is weird cuz it's like is it just
to like have our crew have a good like
meet and greet up you know that go Mina
I'm okay with that
that'd be cool right but now they're
like it's open to everyone and it's
absurd yeah is it a recruiting thief
what do you know what if you join us
presently leave the kids we can spread
the dough at your facility at your
facility yeah I don't know any of it I'm
gonna keep my clothes off I would have
been okay with it feels like within
their group like it's like their retreat
that's fine cuz they're they've been
doing this for forever or whatever but
it was just like hey come try it out
than any other weird [ __ ] comin in to
try it out you know yeah how do you any
members that way though it is the goal
to make new members I don't know what
the goal I thought the nudist colony is
to do what you want to do it's not to be
like an army army what if they're trying
to grow their numbers so they can do
cooler stuff is that the goal be make
it's pretty cool already you should go
over Corning let's say you start the
local softball team right and you only
have like five people and you want to
start a leave you're ready more and more
people and you want to get the bigger
that's a recreational thing where you
want money and you want beer I don't
know what the I don't I'm not a nudist I
don't understand the entire mindset
that's what I don't get if they recruit
I'd be I figure they'd be like okay
we'll fill out an application come check
it out and then like the people there
should be like a vetting process right
yeah and the people who are working
there or who've been in there for a long
time I think yeah this guy's pretty cool
it's been two weeks it's not creepy at
all and then they a little bit you know
but it's like the people were like knows
guys [ __ ] weird as [ __ ] he just
showed up doing cannonballs with a
sagging nuts um
Boulder the whole time boners don't
bring Eric he's always bringing that
telephoto [ __ ] lens and he's always
hard he's always he's always taking
pictures with the boulder you know like
that's that guy's weird
I hate Eric yeah so the head of this
which Erica with his nudist group he
goes by a naked Jeff I like that
yourself
[ __ ] great with names like think
you've such good names to everything
it's not that creative though but it's
so simple it's catchy
Eddie's proud he's proud of his cause
maybe you made that maybe you made a fit
in and see because these [ __ ] cameras
already pretend like this is me looking
at you but this should be really looking
at you I guess the title of the event is
naked pull of slides yeah okay it's
ridiculously you can camera he was new
daddy I want to talk to you mega Jeff
and nude Nancy yes a naked Jeff here he
was saying that nudity does not equal
sex true suggests the suggestions that
it's not appropriate for children is
implying that yes things are happening
at nude events that aren't appropriate
for children which is not true and so
you're just saying like they're really
family-friendly like that's what I mean
it's like it's a new concept to the
Western world yeah so for them they
immediately think perversion and
weirdness yeah so they were just saying
like you know they were just trying to
create like a safe space for nudists and
like an event that's fun for people that
enjoy that type of culture and they were
trying to make this event like a
recurring event like something like once
a month or something but then now this
petition thing is happening and they're
even attacking the location as to where
this is gonna be taking place yeah yeah
yeah and then so now naked dresses like
ours function the self and leisure
center is not organizing this event so
like stop attacking them and so now
they've created a counter-petition that
now has 4,000 signatures and the title
is shut down the petition to shut down
the nudes lighting event I mean what do
they imagine like as soon as you walk in
there's two guys sucking each other's
off while there's kids running around
like what the [ __ ] dude Bieber so
freaked out my new
it's [ __ ] crazy well you know what
though I feel like okay so like we spa
used to be a different place when it was
majority Koreans yeah once the
mainstream America got like you want to
say white people no no it's not just
it's literally like there's there's the
gay community there's all kinds right
like but there's a lot of like weird
things that go down like guys are
sucking each other off and then like
they go in the cops pull them out and
then like that happened yeah I thought
like the security guard is our friend
like I'm a fan so then like we would
talk and I'm like so what kind of stuff
have you been like whatever and use like
yeah my just the other day this dude got
caught I had to tell them hey you can't
do that here and you know cops had to
pull them out and you know they're he's
bad lying because ruin everything but
like there's protocol there's just like
bathing culture there's like there's
already things set in place like for
people that have been doing it for a
while right it's like obviously you
don't suck each other off in the
bathhouse some of the difference might
be that everything in America is run by
business yeah and so these type of
events are now business like I don't
know the other cultures but like we spa
here is a name to make money to get
people to get in here and same with this
now this raging waters is a company yeah
and I think that's why people may be
upset like it feels like raging waters
is a private thing but it feels like a
public thing yeah you know what I mean
that's why people are getting upset I
think in a Promotora [ __ ] happens all
over the place like there's people I've
heard of people are [ __ ] up churches
everything yeah anyway Boy Scouts
everything agree and then other side of
the world to any sort of nudity is so
[ __ ] crazy like holy [ __ ] it's a
nipple but in Europe it's all over
advertising oh I in on ancient statues
yeah right and that's it but it's like
what it's censored so much like even if
Tiffany can post a photo and it's just
like an outline of her nipple and a
shirt and these [ __ ] dweebs would be
like oh my god it's sitting and it just
[ __ ] loser [ __ ] yeah I think that's
what it is is that nudity here is worse
than violence yeah violence is excel
he is not yeah like you can show someone
getting [ __ ] murdered on TV on movies
and [ __ ] but if you show a nipple
they'll freak the [ __ ] out like it's
[ __ ] weird yeah so like in the
description of the counter-petition they
say there's an upcoming event in Calgary
that really concerns some people who are
who are apparently unaware that they
have genitals under their clothes that's
so weak like what do they expect like
all kids are gonna be there and then all
these pedophiles they just can't wait to
go over there to start like [ __ ] kids
or like whatever is that what they're
thinking yeah pretty much they're saying
like this is like a candy store for
predators this is weird
I just want to swim and play and I think
if I if you know if I had kids I would
want them to see as many people make it
because one it desensitizes it and two
it creates this idea of like Oh a lot of
people are [ __ ] ugly you don't mean
they were all human yeah yeah yeah like
I don't want them going up thinking like
everybody's perfect and sculpted and
like especially female like girls like
growing up thinking like all girls
should be this because that's what they
see in magazines and all that if you go
to if you go to the spa I mean you'll
see saggy titties yeah shaggy Bella's
sound like big yeah it's disgusting
but there you go you feel better about
yourself right you're like you know I'm
not so bad
cities are that saggy we're no question
though that have a better about myself
yes forever were to have a daughter
around like four or five years old you'd
be okay with her like seeing Bart
walking around naked yep
like what I drew up like that so I wish
I could say yes to that oh it's weird a
little bit I I'd be cool with you know
all of us being naked at the time but I
didn't grow up like that so even having
I think we even had this discussion like
taking a shot like a bath with like
taiko right if it's not what you're
about
be quiet and then where's that where's
the age that it's okay it feels weird I
think I think it's the start of it
though I think it's like if we teleport
a horny little daughter yeah it's weird
right yeah if you've been doing it we
have the golden skin our and all that
stuff and we've been doing
Skinner what does it call I didn't want
to I wasn't gonna say anything exciting
what it sounds stupid I thought it was a
thing not the golden hours father : ah
so the minute the kids born that one
shower dude wrong topic it's called the
golden hour power out the baby on your
skin for an hour right and if we started
from that point I think it'd be okay but
then where's the age
how about yeah he's at 12 okay yeah cuz
like I used to show I like when he was a
baby but I did like I remember bathing
with my mom in third grade cuz in okay
so bathing culture in Japan is totally
different
we share the tub together as a family
all that stuff and that's bonding time
so that's like time when you just like
relax and it's like having the Jacuzzi
time it's the salient Italian dinner
time yeah it's on our day and you can't
it's like sometimes you just can't wait
to take a bath with your mom or your
family or whatever so you could go in
the bath and then that's when you just
chill out and talk about live you called
it a hot tub that more America would
understand exactly it's like it's like a
jacuzzi
but the only thing is you're naked but
even if you said naked hot tub I've had
more America would understand yeah yeah
it is different because of the shape of
our tubs are doing yeah yeah I'm clam
scrubbing my nuts to cut off HB never
hopefully well I guess I know yeah I
don't know either that's true cuz at my
age I would I would go in the bath with
my family yeah like they're like what
seniors and stuff like and we would
still go in there and talk yeah your age
period yeah but then like you know as a
baby weird like this 8 to 15 yeah
because there's also like when there's
something where like when is it
appropriate for a little girl to still
kiss her dad on the lips mm-hmm
I know people that still kiss now and
they're mine I just mean times on the
worse we get we tried to you know it was
cuz it felt like natural yeah so they
just love them so much right so just
kiss him everywhere and then try to kiss
him on the lips but it's weird because
this fall only has his mouth open
like this like this and he's like uh
kind of weird like I do you get like a
string of slobber if you call his mouth
I can do it yeah let you just lonesome
all over the place but the night that's
all wait till later
do you even know what you're doing the
rare times that you doesn't have a fist
in as well yeah yeah ah ha I'm surprised
how his lips is not chapped
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]